I'm always always having the munchies we
back to chance
the most expensive caviar in the world
this $200 but the caveat yes that's
about a gram
yeah so change single kernel salt gold
hops how much for this habit $295
what is this under $1,000 with or
without tanks boy have $5 kernels look
at the particle that's a big-ass bird
this is my 24 karat gold dusted real
gold on there you can eat that you can
eat gold what you thinking oh you know
three-year-olds or seven euros in gold
and your way to the 13-14 embargo roll
it in old what's going on with this gold
and that you can eat tell them about
that you can eat pure gold
I'm never eating gold before it you're
getting it on this is that toaster is
the other side of everybody ain't doing
this man
no planning around you basically like
them on me go
[Music]
it's a lot to to take him I think it
makes my skin shine and glisten all my
records they eventually go gold or
platinum that's what you'd really talk
about having expensive tastes for
someone who's very health conscious like
myself no you need to get more
health-conscious what does this the
ingredients that you have and what does
this like do for us like watching your
calories and all that I wouldn't worry
about it just go hard just go hard who's
counting calories
[Music]
we gotta show the rap thing is going
excellent for me but if not I'm gonna go
with show all right you can slang some
ice cream listen listen listen listen
pay attention to me do you think it's
really worth it talk to leave a comment
subscribe to the GQ chump for more most
expensively [ __ ]